hey friends so check it out about a
month ago I got a hold of a set of jelly
POI from ignis Pixel and the question is
are they any good well walk along with
me as I find
[Music]
[Applause]
out Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with with you the love of Po
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I am coming at
you with a review of jelly poy by ignis
pixel but before we dive in I just want
to give a quick shout out to the Friends
of the channel big thanks to dark monk
fire Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Tera light toys spinballs
and Ultra poy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non- business
friend of the channel Becca Becken thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission so
ignis's jelly poy are centered around
something that's been a long-standing
frustration in the PO spinning World
namely programable po look really
beautiful they create awesome trails and
awesome patterns in midair the only
problem is when there's any kind of
collision especially a collision with
your body those polycarbonate housings
really hurt so is it possible to create
programmable poy that have a Sofer body
to them and still retain all of the
awesome features of other programmable
poy my answer to that question is kind
of but I also think they're burying the
lead a little bit on this let me explain
why but hey first up let's go through my
usual review rubric simply because I
don't think I've seen another review out
there for
these
features so jelly POI are a set of
programmable LED poy made by ignis pixel
and they are I believe 24 pixels long
you can see that they have this uh kind
of long housing to them that is 3D
printed and they have like six veins in
it every other vein has a line of ball
bearings in it to kind of add some
weight and then the LEDs themselves are
in the center of the housing it of
course is connected via a nylon rope to
a set of their programmable handles
which are also awesome and the whole
thing connects via Bluetooth to ignis
pixel's uh app its smartphone app that
allows you to bring up different images
onto the PO and even create custom
programs and keep track of your POI
workouts it's pretty
awesome ease of
use so jelly poy have a one button
interface here which in some other sets
of LED po programmable or otherwise that
can sometimes be challenging it's made
easier in this case via the smartphone
app which I personally think is the gold
standard for ease of use when it comes
to flow art smartphone apps and
specifically with programming the only
challenge there really is if you have
like a custom program that you would
like to do to a song that's really not
possible with the app I've tried doing
it you can create a custom timeline and
you can set different Graphics to post
for different amounts of time but you
can't really do that while you're
putting it up against a piece of music
so uh any specific program that you
would do for as a performance is going
to be a little challenging but if you're
just doing a gig where you got to show a
company's logo for a little while or you
have some cool graphic you want to throw
onto your phone and put onto the poy
that stuffs pretty
easy
brightness so I'm just going to say that
I have yet to find any set of
programmable poy on the market that
aren't blindingly bright if you crank
that setting all the way to the Max and
these are no different I can see them
quite clearly in the
daytime battery
life so as many of you know I have two
tests that I do every single time I get
a new set of LED POI one to see how
badly I can punish the battery and one
to see how the POI function with a more
normal use case so for the first test I
set all the LEDs to Pure White and crank
up the brightness all the way and with
the Jelly poy they last of an hour when
I do that which is not surprising
programmable poy usually don't have
terribly great battery life but the
surprise for me is that switching over
to doing a rainbow mode at medium
brightness gave me 10 hours of battery
life with these which is shocking to me
I don't know that I can think of any
other LED POI that I have ever tested
that have that big a spread between the
bright white test and the rainbow test
it was uh quite
dramatic durability
so straight up durability is kind of the
Achilles heel of any set of programmable
POI like bubble poy also made by ignis
pixel the jelly poy are made by 3D
printing the housings which means that
they're essentially creating layers of
plastic that are connected together with
each other now those layers of plastic
also create points where there can be a
potential weakness and or failure I have
yet to make that happen with a set of
the jelly POI I have made it happen with
the bubble POI so I know it's possible I
do think however that having all the
LEDs centrally located inside uh the
housing is probably going to make it so
these are going to be a little bit more
durable than uh the bubble poy but we'll
have to see all right so now the real
question that I know you all are waiting
for how exactly do they feel well the
answer to that is surprisingly good I
really don't know what I expected when I
first picked these up I think that at
this point I kind of just have the this
thing in the back of my head that
whenever I see a rod form factor set of
programmable poy I instantly think
they're going to look really pretty but
they're going to be a pain in the butt
to spin and that was not the case I was
pleasantly surprised to find that the
weight distribution was such that they
felt a lot like other sets of LED POI
that I've used over the years that are
not programmable POI there's a lot more
mass towards the end rather than having
it distributed evenly throughout the
entire length of the head and that meant
that things like stalls and plane breaks
were actually a lot cleaner and a lot
easier with these than they are normally
with programmable poy but you ask what
about the promise of jelly poy in the
first place do they hurt less than
spinning other programmable poy and the
answer to that is yes with some caveats
so are they softer than any other set of
programmable POI that I have used yes
absolutely by a huge margin yes does
that mean that there is no possibility
that they will hurt you when you use
them the answer is no so so lowkey the
first day that I was using these uh I
have to admit that a few hours later I
was finding that my thumb was sore and I
couldn't figure out why and then I
suddenly realized it was because I was
doing a lot of one-handed spiral wraps
with these jelly POI and that all of
that wonderful weight that is being
added by these ball bearings got
transferred directly into my thumb joint
whenever I completed one of those spiral
reps so it's still in order of magnitude
better than other sets of programmable
poy that I have used but um it's not
going to be like say using podp you you
are still going to have to watch out for
those moments where you're making rapid
and hard contact with the POI but truth
be told I actually don't think that
that's the best selling point for these
POI just as an experiment I brought them
in the studio with me yesterday to see
how they would work with me dancing I
have to admit I was shocked when I
discovered that the weight distribution
in these po made them a perfect fit for
my style of dance whether it was doing
stalls or plane breaks on the beat or
really rapid changes in Direction when I
wanted to make Tempo changes these were
shockingly good at keeping up like yes
it's considered the Holy Grail of
programmable po to have sets that don't
hurt when you use them but it's also
kind of the Holy Grail of programmable
poy to have sets that more or less
handle like non-programmable Po and
these are pretty close to that so
ultimately I'm actually pretty happy
with them I don't know how often I'm
going to find use cases for them simply
because I just don't do gigs but it's
nice to know that they are an option
when I am looking for something that can
Flash up a variety of different graphics
and that handle pretty close to what I'm
used to with my practice
poy
price jelly poy 24s from ignis Pixel
sell for
$375 a pair without the program able LED
handles but with the programmable LED
handles they are
$465 the company is located abroad
though so uh do bear in mind that
shipping might be a little bit of a
challenge if you happen to go down that
route they're available over at ignis
pixel.com and now I will leave you off
with some footage of these in action
[Music]
enjoy
it
[Music]
do you have a set of the jelly po 24s
what do you think of them leave me a
comment and let me know also be sure to
like share And subscribe to help other
people find this video and to help my
channel
[Music]
grow this video would not be possible
without all of my amazing patreon
supporters in particular I'd love to
shout out my flow patrons who are listed
on screen right now uh if you'd like to
check out some of my other LED prop
review I will go ahead and include a
link to a playlist of those videos down
in the description as well as a link to
my patreon if you wouldd like to support
the channel cuz every little bit helps
thanks so much for watching make sure to
get out and flow today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon take care now
peace